Speaker 1: Our friend, Congressman Jamie
Raskin, who's been a guest on this program,
says that Donald Trump will likely end his life
behind bars. This I have to see because I have a
very, very difficult time believing that. Newsweek
reports Trump likely to be indicted will end life,
quote, behind bars. Congressman says former
President Donald Trump will likely be indicted
and spend the rest of his life behind bars.
Representative Jamie Raskin said on Saturday.
Raskin is a maryland Democrat and served on the
House Select Committee investigating the Capitol
riots. The panel spent months probing Trump's role
in the insurrection. Raskin reflected about the
significance of the report issued by the committee
during an appearance on Yahoo News's Skullduggery
podcast Saturday. The Democratic lawmaker said
he, quote, would be really would be surprised if
Attorney General Merrick Garland did not indict
Trump for his alleged role in the riot, adding
that it's so clear that the president intended
to interfere with the election certification.
Raskin went on to say, I do think it's very,
very important that we establish that it's not
just footsoldiers, but kingpins who are prosecuted
and that it's just wrong to send hundreds of foot
soldiers to jail and leave the very clear kingpin
unprosecuted. He added that Trump could spend the
rest of his life in prison if he's convicted
on January six charges. There's just deep
culpability from the very beginning in everything
that Donald Trump did. I'm very serious about him
facing the consequences and paying for the cost
of his action. He could spend the remaining days
of his misanthropic life behind bars, presumably
with Secret Service agents. I would love for Jamie
Raskin to be correct here. I really would. The
blatant criminality and flouting of the law by
Donald Trump is absolutely stunning and appalling.
And we hope that the safeguards we have in place
are actually robust and strong enough that they
can hold someone like Donald Trump accountable. I
would love for Jamie Raskin to be right that that
accountability is going to be prison time. I don't
think that it is. And again, it goes through let's
think through the steps. First step is Donald
Trump has to be indicted. Hasn't happened yet, but
maybe it will. Trump gets indicted. Next step is,
does it even go to trial? Or is Trump as a former
president who will have the best of the best
legal advice going to strike a deal and make a
deal either where he doesn't have to admit to
any guilt, but he pays fines or he has to plead
guilty to something minor. And the consequence
of jail time, prison time is not even on the
table. If you get beyond that and you say, okay,
he's going to have to go to trial and it's going
to include the possibility of a prison sentence.
How do you get a jury to fairly evaluate a former
president's actions? I don't know who you can find
that wouldn't bring a strong preconceived notion
and preconceived opinion about Trump's guilt or
innocence. And by the way, as I've said before,
if you can find people who really have no opinion,
I would wonder whether where they've been for
the last six years and whether these are even
really the people competent enough to serve on
a jury. Although it's a jury of your peers, I
understand everybody gets to serve. So how do you
even put a jury together if you then get a guilty
verdict that sticks, that doesn't get appealed?
There may not necessarily be prison time. And
if there is a guilty verdict and if there is
prison time and Trump gets sentenced, older,
wealthy folks close to 80 years old with prison
sentences use every possibility available to them,
every health issue that they have, and argue
for house arrest instead of actual prison. So
I believe that if everything went perfectly
indictment, serious charges, conviction,
sentencing, that even includes prison time. I
think you get a suspended sentence or at the very,
very worst for Trump, you get home confinement.
So I know he's Mr. Perfect Health six 3 to 39,
healthiest president ever. I assure you that will
be a very different story painted about his health
if all of a sudden prison is on the table. And
I would bet anything that Trump doesn't see a
day in a jail or prison cell. If you disagree with
me. I want to hear from you. I just don't see it.